good morning John I love Tumblr text
posts as they rise to the top of the
most massive slush pile in the history
of the universe getting six or even
seven figures of notes cumulating the
endorsement of seemingly everyone they
become almost objectively great like no
one could argue with their greatness and
when I read them I usually agree
negative incite a fascinating
explanation a truly daring set of puns
those text posts that break out into
virality are the height of a forum a
pretty weird forum agree but I also like
the Tumblr text post because like all
media they say a lot about the culture
that creates and honors and promotes
them here's one that I came across quite
a while ago that kind of stuck with me
but I'm really terrified of is leaving
an average ordinary life with a regular
job an invariable routine planned
holidays an average household fixed
responsibilities and not doing anything
different to be remembered by this post
has around half a million notes and that
makes me a little worried because John
as you have for some reason repeatedly
driven home over and over again probably
because you struggle with this quite a
lot yourself oblivion is inevitable and
someday there will be no one left to
remember anything let alone you or me
being remembered forever is not a good
goal because it is not an achievable
goal but that argument doesn't work for
you take a look at me I am what people
call successful I've had more than my
share of interesting life experiences
I've toured in a rock band been written
about in The New Yorker helped raise
over 2 million dollars for charity crash
course is watched in thousands of
schools and I don't know if you heard
about this but recently I interviewed
the president so you might ask when was
it for me when I knew that I had made it
when was the moment when I had the
success statue and I got to put it on
this shelf right here next Abbie was it
when I was first recognized in public or
when we got a hundred thousand
subscribers or a million subscribers and
when I first was paying my bills with
you - which day was it when I became
perpetually satisfied and always happy
yeah it was none of the days here's the
thing about success if you're smart
enough and you're dedicated enough and
lucky enough and sacrifice enough you
too will get to find out that none of it
exists it's made up it's just it's not a
real thing you get successes but you
don't get success the whole of
everything of it does not lie on that
arbitrary yet remarkable thing that you
did that everyone says yes that that
counts I'd have those thing
and they do not bring long-term
satisfaction the satisfaction the joy
that comes from solving problems and
making things and oftentimes the
recognition isn't even a necessary part
of the process so if I have any advice
for the 500,000 people who either liked
or reblogged that text post on tumblr
here it is instead of thinking about
what you will and won't accomplish in
your life think about the problems that
you have helped solve and you will help
solve in the things that you're gonna
help make and that you've already helped
make I don't think I'm alone in feeling
like the things that we help making the
problems that we help solve those are
the things that really matter the things
that actually affect the world and that
actually make us happy and maybe every
person is unremarkable in that we all
make things every day we make happiness
and we make families and we make
sandwiches and most fantastically of all
we make ourselves John I'll see you on
Tuesday
endscreen and you know why we love video
games so much because they give us clear
defined problems to solve and value
Laden achievements to online I love it
which is why games with Hank officially
today is back with a new series and
green plays The Sims and of course you
can adjust booby size to the beat of the
music
meet Jimmy Carter he is like 90 years
old so let's go ahead and make an old
man oh good so so Jimmy Carter I mean I
guess we could give him emo hair oh no
no what about uh yeah you look great
you're in great shape Jimmy leader of
the free world that's not a lifetime
wish Jimmy Carter you already got to do
that